THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: TRACE GALLAGHER
WITHOUT REPORT.
JOINING ME NOW, DailyMail.com,
PIERS MORGAN WHO BY THE WAY HAS
BECOME A FRIEND OF MINE AND HE
WAS ONCE A COMPETITOR.
I NEVER DISLIKED HIM THAT EXCEPT
FOR THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> WE WILL DEBATE THAT ONE DAY.
>> Sean: HAVE COME TO ADMIRE
YOUR FLIGHT AND YOUR HUMOR.
YOU ARE VERY IMPRESSIVE AND I
READ YOUR STUFF ALL THE TIME.
LIBERALS SCREAMING TO IMPEACH
TRUMP, YOU HAD A --
YOU WERE ON FIRE.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND I
WANT TO OFFER MY DEEPEST
SYMPATHY TO JUSSIE SMOLLETT.
IT MUST BE OFFERED TO HAVE
POST-TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
FROM SOMETHING THAT YOU FAKED
YOURSELF.
THE POOR GUY.
OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO HIM.
ALL THOSE NIGHTMARES ABOUT
DEADEYE OR DID I NOT GIVE THEM
THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE
CHECK I PAID TO STAGE THESE GUYS
DO THIS ATTACK?
DO ME A FAVOR.
THAT GOT ME ANGRY.
LET'S TURN TO THIS ISSUE OF THE
REPORT.
THERE WERE 400 PAGES BUT WHAT
WAS THE REPORT TO SET UP TO BE?
IT WAS SET UP TO INVESTIGATE.
MUELLER WAS TO INVESTIGATE
WHETHER THERE WAS A CONSPIRACY
BY DONALD TRUMP OR HIS CAMPAIGN
TEAM WITH THE RUSSIANS TO
BASICALLY FIX THE ELECTION.
I CAN'T IMAGINE A MORE SERIOUS
CHARGE AGAINST ANY SERVING
PRESIDENT.
THEY BETRAY THEIR COUNTRY WITH A
FOREIGN ENEMY TO FIX U.S.
ELECTION AND FOR TWO YEARS THE
MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY AND THE
DEMOCRATS AND SCREAMING LIBERAL
CELEBRITIES LIKE JUSSIE SMOLLETT
WHO LED THE CHARGE ON THIS HAVE
SCREAMED COLLUSION, COLLUSION!
THIS WAS A DONE DEAL.
MUELLER WAS THE SAVIOR, THE MAN
ON THE WHITE HORSE RIDING INTO
TOWN TO TAKE DOWN PRESIDENT
TROMP ON COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA
HE WOULD BE EXPOSED AS A TRAITOR
AND THIS WOULD BE THE END OF HIS
PRESIDENCY.
THE MUELLER REPORT COMES OUT AND
IT TURNS OUT IT WAS ALL
NONSENSE.
IT WAS TO QUOTE DONALD TRUMP
"FAKE NEWS."
I TURNED THE DAY AFTER THE FULL
REPORT WAS PUBLISHED AND LOOKED
AT THE PAPERS,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHO BOTH
WON PULITZER PRIZES FOR THEIR
COVERAGE NEITHER OF THEM
REMEMBER TO MENTION THEIR BANNER
HEADLINES THE DAY AFTER THE FULL
PUBLICATION OF THE FULL REPORT,
NOW THEY REMEMBER TO MENTION
THAT THE CONCLUSION BY MUELLER
WAS THAT THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
INSTEAD THEY WENT FOR MORE TROMP
BASHING.
I TURNED TO CABLE NEWS, SOME OF
YOUR RIVALS.
A TWO MOVED VARIES QUICKLY FROM
COLLUSION THAT HAD BEEN
SCREAMING ABOUT FOR TWO YEARS TO
NO OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
LET'S ANALYZE THAT FOR A COUPLE
OF SECONDS.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT
DONALD TRUMP DONALD TRUMP
COMMITTED REPEATED OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE OVER A CRIME THAT HE
NOW AS WE ALL KNOW DID NOT
COMMIT?
HE IS TRYING TO OBSTRUCT PEOPLE
FROM INVESTIGATING SOMETHING HE
SAYS HE DIDN'T DO ANY SPECIAL
COUNSEL HAS CONFIRMED HE DIDN'T
DO.
IT IS RIDICULOUS, IT IS A FARCE,
IT IS MAKING A MOCKERY OF
AMERICA IN THE SAME WAY THAT
BACK IN MY COUNTRY OVER BREXIT.
OUR DEPARTURE FROM THE
EUROPEAN UNION UNION THE PEOPLE
WHO LOST VOTED REMAINED AND I WS
ONE OF THEM WHO REFUSED TO
ACCEPT THE RESULTS.
THE LIBERALS HERE ARE REFUSING
TO ACCEPT RESULTS IN 2016.
HILLARY WON THE POPULAR VOTE.
WHO CARES?
NOW THEY REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE MUELLER REPORT.
THE ONE THAT THEY SAID WOULD BE
THE FINAL PIECE.
>> Sean: IS THIS A DISGRACE?
>> IT IS A DISGRACE!
>> Sean: THAT WAS SO WELL
DONE.
I CAN'T TOP THAT.
YOU ARE EDGY.
THE DAILY MAIL IS EDGY.
THIS IS OUTRIGHT LIE AT
CONSPIRACY THEORIES BASED ON
ANONYMOUS SOURCES.
WHAT IS THE FALLOUT?
I DON'T THINK THEY EVER GET IS
OF THE FAKENESS BRANDING OF
DONALD TRUMP.
>> I'M ACTUALLY STAGGERED WITH
CNN AND I HAVE A GREAT RESPECT
FOR THE NETWORK, I HAVE FRIENDS
THERE.
THEY HAVE GONE COMPLETELY IN THE
TANK ANTI-TROMP.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY HAVE DONE
THAT OTHER THAN IT GIVES THEM A
LOT OF MONEY I GUESS.
IT DAMAGES THE CREDIBILITY AND I
WISH THEY WEREN'T DOING IT.
I WISH THAT SOMEWHERE IN AMERICA
IT WOULD GO BACK TO REPRESENTING
TROMP AND A FAIR WAY.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY SAY LOOK, THE
MUELLER REPORT CAME BACK AND
SAID NO COLLUSION.
MOVE ON.
THE DEMOCRATS FUELED BY THE
MEDIA TRY TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
THIS AND I'M TELLING YOU WHAT
WILL HAPPEN, DONALD TRUMP WILL